I just texted my parents that I'm gonna
go drag racing on the bridge from Greece
and that I asked them to remember me
well
we're here today to drag race some fast
expensive cars I'm scared as much as I
love looking at fast cars
I've never been in one that's kind of
terrifying to me it's something I've
always wanted to do I love fast things I
love dangerous things I love adrenaline
I hope that my screaming isn't going to
distract them I'm gonna be screaming
Andy he's my driver for today so how
fast what would be going over a hundred
miles an hour for sure do you think the
Ferrari can beat me that is one of the
fastest cars on the face that's what I
heard this is my driver Riley this is a
faster car I think it's gonna beat that
I don't see how Andy especially at Sandy
driving so I don't think he's gonna win
oh [ __ ] talk you guys I'm ready for this
to be over feeling really confident I'm
not gonna lie yeah I feel like this
would not be here if there wasn't danger
oh man Quinta can eat [ __ ] all that
matters is that I won I loved every
minute of it I now get why people drive
fast cars go so rather buy a nice purse
I picked Riley to be my driver in
Ferrari so we're gonna kick some butt
I pick Amy to drive me in the GTR
because I feel like he knows what he's
doing and we're going to get to surf I
win don't you look at me do I look like
I'm fast the car looks bad no one's
asking you to run it roof they're going
down
that was exhilarating I want to do it
again like seven more times how did they
do that like sexy like get out of the
car there's no sexy way to get out of
these cars not at all it was like being
on a roller coaster but like when you
have the control over it yeah so we won
we're the winners and now we're gonna
forget it read each other in the finals
here's the problem though is that we
both had Riley as our driver Riley why
don't you come in here and you tell us
who you'd rather drive
I think the GTR oh okay Riley has a big
crush on
we almost hit the camera guy we almost
hit the cop right there you know Freddie
took some risk I am the winner of drag
racing I beat everybody I hated every
minute of it
and it's a victory and I'm getting an
icy pop as a reward at the end of the
day doesn't matter who won because we
have ice cream congratulations
yeah that was exhilarating a hundred
percent would do it again mm-hmm I'm
proud that I did twice I think this
should be my job now I'm gonna change
careers I think I caught the bug now how
people do it once and they catch the bug
and they want to keep going yeah the
next time is to see how much him and I
scream well you girls are driving yeah
exactly
that's my speed video for sure screaming
girls drag racing iconic location Greece
like one good-looking dude and me